the t results right advantage they
enable you to rephrase trig identities
and trigonometry functions as algebra
right the whole point is that we're very
very good at algebra so we can sort of
take advantage of that
okay with these questions but it's much
broader right
is just where we're starting because
that's the most recent results yeah
so let's look at 5a first it starts with
questions that you can do without t
results
right because that way you start to get
the hang of it but then it'll move into
questions where it's very impractical to
do
without team results okay so this is the
first identity
we'll sort of assume that and they'll
say assuming that blah blah blah blah
blah
but usually it's up to you too
so here is an identity that you might
see okay and because it's the first one
right
it's got big flashing lights around it
saying use the t
results because there's literally a tan
theta on two the
definition of t in there and the next
example i'm going to show you is not
nearly so obvious but you can start to
see right now i'm going to substitute so
the first thing i'm going to say
is let t equal
so if this is the case i can say this
this is equivalent to all right now i
need to remember
what my cause is like doubling ten items
i'll say the left hand side is equal to
well i'll just
once you've established it like having
just done this you no longer ever need
to prove this
unless this is a good question you can
just use the results so
i'm going to have so cos theta i have
derived
as this right so i'm just going to
replace it yeah 1 minus t
squared one is plus t squared so i'm
going to have
minus what's tan yep it comes from
double i
double angle identity right so it's
going to be 2t
on 1 minus t squared is that okay okay
and then here i have minus now that's
just t
isn't it so far so good hey so i've got
one plus t
squared so if i told you look i've got a
bit of an algebraic let's see just
simplify this
what would be the first step watch out
for your sides here okay what cancelling
whatever
i've got these guys here these guys here
they can cancel with each other can't
they right
so i'm gonna have two t on one plus t
squared that's what comes out what am i
gonna get on my numerator now but then
i'm gonna do this one as well
right so i'm gonna have minus yeah so
far so good
plus t 1 minus t
squared is that okay yep okay
two t now what do we do
i better not do the expansion because
i'm probably going to sleep
what am i going to get on my numerator
now so i can save but wait that's
that's t which i define minus s tan
yeah so you can see that two t
minus two we did this substitution how
many like terms i've got
we can still do maths well done after
seven days okay
now you can see what's going on here
right this i can factor out
algae you just simply which leaves me
with one plus t squared on the
denominator so sorry
and one plus t squared on the
denominator so you can cancel and
cancel right and so i can say but wait
that's
that's t which i defined as 10
feet hours on 2
okay so
you can see that like after we did this
substitution
how many trig identities did you think
of answer none
you don't need to think about oh maybe i
should do the pythagorean one or maybe i
should do a double
angle or maybe i should blah blah you
don't worry about any of it you just
do algebra you just simplify we're very
very good at this
right so in some ways it just kind of
makes it you know
automatic right we can do algebra and
simplify that on autopilot
okay does that make sense okay now let's
have a look at five b
the immediate next i didn't tell you
this was slightly less obvious okay
before we even start this let me just
say
like i don't know i don't know what the
proportion a decent proportion of the
questions
which you will do by t results you don't
need t
results for okay and not this particular
lesson but soon
you'll learn there are certain
disadvantages to z results where you're
like if i don't have to use it i won't
okay um but here we can because
here's here's the big red flashy symbol
before you saw a tan thing on two okay
so that's about as obvious and slap you
in the face as we can to say
use t results okay this is almost as
obvious because
can you have a look at the angles that
you've got there right
you've got x's and you've got two x's
right in other words
you've got an angle and you've got
double that angle or
if i say it in reverse you have an angle
and you have
half its angle half its angle that's the
same thing okay
so here see how there's this critical
line here where you define
what t is okay i'm going to define it
just a little bit different here
i'm going to say let t equal instead of
tan theta on 2
it'll be 10x okay
so all the identities i had before
instead of being sine theta cos theta
tan theta
there will be sine 2x cos 2x tan 2x
which is exactly what i have here
okay so now i'll say left hand side i'll
just quote it
and then i will do my substitution okay
so i've got one
minus now think think big because
you guys are going to start to learn
that's that's the long complicated one
it's going to have the 1
minus t squared on the top and the 1
plus t squared on the bottom
and then here sine two x that's going to
be
two t on one plus t squared
okay again after copious redrawing of
that triangle i mentioned it
at the beginning this kind of thing will
become pretty quick to you okay
all right i have a fraction now i've
gotten rid of all of my trig inverted
commas okay
so what would be your first strategy to
simplify this mess
yeah great i've got the same fraction
here denominator on the top the bottom
so i might as well get rid of all in one
hit
i'll multiply the top and the bottom by
one
plus t squared okay that will kill all
the fractions all at once
so i'm going to have a 1 plus t squared
there watch out for your sides here
three one one minus t squared three
and then on the bottom here i have two t
okay
so now what happens here
one plus one three
that's going to become sorry one minus
one will become zebra
yep what do i have here on the top
b squared that'll be plus two t squared
all divided by two t
right which surprisingly equals t
which i define to be 10x
okay that's the right hand side i'm
finished
so you can see again like how would we
have done this if we didn't know what t
results were and the answer is you'd
take these guys
right and you would say well that's cos
squared minus sine squared
that's 2 sine cos and then you'd go from
there and you can
okay but this well it just kind of
happens
automatically always you just simplify
the algebra
uh it's worth saying one of the reasons
why t results are faster
is because you're not writing sides and
causes and tans you're just writing t's
which is just which is faster
okay this is less letters to write more
focusing on what the actual mass is
okay